All right, rapture. You ready to talk
about the rapture?
What was this rapture craze all about?
Again, a particular group of
evangelicals.
A particular group of evangelicals. Not
all evangelicals.
Not all evangelicals.
Yes, we said Mike Winger.
There's only a certain segment of
evangelicals that believe in what's
called
the rapture. This is also
found among Baptists. This is a belief
held among them. Now, let me give you a
little background. I was taught
pre-tribulation rapture. What is that?
According to this belief held among
dispensationalists
taught at Moody Bible Institute in
Chicago, Moody Church
held by Baptists of various persuasions,
there's going to be a 7-year
tribulation.
I was taught that during the seven
years, right at the start, the Lord
Jesus would rapture the church, take the
church out of the earth, and they would
remain with the Lord in heaven because
that would be the time where God's
spirit would be dealing with the Jews.
Some of them taught that during the
seven years, the spirit that's
constraining the Antichrist from arising
would then be removed from the earth.
The spirit would no longer be on the
earth. Now, how does anyone get saved
without the spirit? I don't know. So, I
was taught seven years will be taken up.
Then the antichrist arises, makes a
covenant with the Jews for seven years
and allows them to rebuild the third
temple. And when they finish at the
midpoint, three and a half year mark, he
will turn against them and slaughter
them and persecute them for three and a
half years. Then Jesus comes down
to destroy the antichrist and the saints
will come with him and those who
believed will be transformed
and they will rule with Christ on earth
for a thousand years. This is called the
pre-tribulation rapture theory. There
are debates. There's a group that
believe in the midtri rapture that the
church won't be raptured before the
seven years. They'll be raptured in the
middle of the seven years, right when
the Antichrist turns against the Jews,
three and a half years into the
seven-year tribulation. Now, there's a
third group that says the rapture takes
place at the end of the seven years. And
they believe in the pre-wrath rapture,
meaning the church will be taken up
right at the end of seven years, right
before Christ pours out his wrath on the
Antichrist and his armies.
[Laughter]
You with me there?
So those who believe in the rapture
and the tribulation, there are three
views. What's their tribulation?
The seven years what they call Jacob's
woes. You're learning. You want me to
talk about it, right? because of the
huge embarrassment that these biblically
illiterate buffoons brought on
themselves, giving the enemies of Christ
more opportunity to mock and scoff and
slander the faith because they assigned
the date September 23rd, 24th, we're
going to be raptured. Yeah, I guess you
were left behind.
I was taught and I believe
pre-tribulation rapture. But as I study
and I
grew. I ended up holding to
posttribulation rapture until finally I
gave up on the idea of the tribulation
altogether. Now, what passage do they
use for the rapture? Don't be naive.
It's in the Bible. The rapture is in the
Bible. The word itself is not because
I'm going to tell you where it comes
from. This is their passage.
The Bible does t talk about Christ
snatching up the church to meet him and
the saints who have died and are
wrestling with him in the air. Here it
is.
This is the passage they use. 1
Thessalonians 4:13:18.
I don't know why I'm using the Revised
Standard Version, but that's okay. But
we do not want you to be un uninformed,
brothers and sisters, about those who
have died so that you may not grieve as
others
do who have no hope. For since we
believe that Jesus died
and rose again, even so through Jesus,
God will bring with him those who have
died. For this we declare to you by the
word of the Lord, that we who are alive,
who are left unto the coming of the
Lord, will by no means precede those who
have died. For the Lord himself, with a
cry of command, with the archangel's
call, with the sound of God trumpet,
will descend from heaven, and the dead
in Christ will rise first. Now watch.
Then we who are alive, who are left,
will be caught up,
raptured up, taken up. This is where
they get it. In the clouds together with
them to meet the Lord near. Now notice
what it doesn't say. It doesn't say
you'll be caught up and be taken to
heaven.
You'll be caught up in the clouds to
meet the Lord in the sky, in the
horizon, in the air. Not heaven.
It's a different word alto together.
You see it there?
Yeah. But they're not going with the
Greek. They're going with the Latin for
the word rapture. I'm going to show you
the Latin. And so we will be with the
Lord forever. Therefore, encourage one
another with these words. Now, what's
the word for caught up in the Latin?
Now, let's go to the Latin Vulgate.
Okay,
this is the passage. Now, when you read
it, it sounds like Yeah, they're right.
Right.
Sounds like they're right. Correct.
Right here. Here's the do a Latin online
for free. Okay.
So, you can see it right here.
Okay. Let's go here. So, this is why
they embarrass themselves.
Now, how many of them you think are
going to lose their faith and think
Christianity is a joke? Right? Then we
who are alive
shall be taken up together with them in
the clouds.
What's the word?
Rapier.
I don't know how to speak Latin, so
don't condemn me. Right?
See, let's see what the word rap is.
Is a Latin word, specifically the first
person plural future passive form of the
verb rap.
We shall be snatched or we shall be
caught up. It is found in first 17 of
the Latin Vulgate and the original
English word rapture. See where it comes
from?
Comes from Latin.
See that?
Everyone got that?
This is where they get
the rapture from. So when you say there
is no rapture in the Bible, say then you
don't know your Bible.
It's the word caught up in Latin which
in Greek harpo I believe. We'll double
check but anyway
will be caught up. So now this is there
it says the church will be caught up.
Now what does it mean?
Yep. What does it mean? Well, if you
read this in the context of scripture,
when our Lord comes down, we who believe
will be caught up to meet the saints in
the air in the sky and we will be
transformed in the twinkling of a line
eye at the last trumpet. and then we
will rule with Christ on earth.
There is nothing about 7-year
tribulation in the New Testament.
Nothing. At most, what you get in
Revelation is 3 and 1/2 years, 42
months, 1,260 days, times half a time.
Right?
What they do is they quote Daniel 9:27
and think that week of years, seven
years refers to the antichrist arising
to make a covenant with Israel. Whereas
when you read the context has nothing to
do with the second coming. It has to do
with the ruler, the Messiah, confirming
the covenant curses and the Mosaic law
by bringing up the Romans to destroy the
city and the temple
as a consequence of their rebellion. So
he confirms the covenant. What covenant?
The blessings and the curses mentioned
in the covenant. Right? If you read
Leviticus 26 and Deuteronomy 28-30,
there are list of blessings and curses.
So he's confirming that the curses that
God warned through Moses have now fallen
on the nation because they broke
covenant faithfulness. And the week he's
talking about is not the week
that has to do with the Lord returning.
It has to do with the seven years that
culminates in the destruction of the
temple and the city Jerusalem.
Is it a coincidence the Jewish war
lasted seven years? From AD66 to 73. Is
it a coincidence that in the middle of
those seven years the temple was
destroyed stopping sacrifices?
You will be blown away by by the
precision, the meticulous accuracy of
the time period because it all
terminates when Jesus shows up. It is
cut off and then the city and the temple
destroyed right after him exactly as
Daniel said and the Lord appears during
the timeline that the Messiah is
supposed to appear. A fact admitted by
Rashi, a rabbi. Did you know that?
You guys got to watch it. That's another
supernatural miraculous proof that
Daniel's inspired and Jesus Messiah.
Even the rabbis have a hard time with
Daniel. I'm not exaggerating. The two
prophecies that God has used to lead
Jews to trust in Jesus. Isaiah 53 and
Daniel 9.
Now I did series on Daniel timeline. I
will start a playlist
Daniel timeline. It's there. Boom.
Messianic prophecy series. You see how
skinny I was right here? I was doing a
lot of cardio and I was like frail. I
look sickly like I was on heroin. Can
you pray for me? Let's see why they
think this points to the rapture at the
end.
And why? They'd be wrong. Know therefore
understand from the time that the word
So when does the period start? When the
word goes out to restore and rebuild
Jerusalem on the time of an anointed
prince, the the word anointed is
Mashiach naged anointed prince there
shall be seven weeks. 7* 7 that's 49
years. 62 weeks 62 * 7 that's 434 years.
So if you add 434 and 49, 483 years,
there will be 483 years from the decree
to rebuild Jerusalem until Messiach
Nagid, the Messiah prince, shows up. 483
years. You with me there? Okay.
All right.
There shall be seven weeks, 40 60 weeks.
7 * 7 weeks. That's weeks of years.
That's 49 years. It's actually Hebrews
says 7 sevens. 62 weeks. 62 * 7. 434 49
483. It shall be built again with
streets and moat. So they're going to
start rebuilding Jerusalem, but in a
triple time, but they're going to do it
under duress, which is actually what
happened. They're under foreign
occupation
after the 62 weeks. So after
the 434 years, the anointed one,
Messiah, will be cut off, will be
killed, and shall have nothing. Then
what will happen? Then the troops of the
prince, now notice who the prince is,
the prince is the Messiah. This is where
people get it wrong.
Okay, I want you to listen to this.
Who's the prince in the context?
The Messiah. There are not two princes.
The prince is the Messiah. It says the
prince will send his troops to do what?
Destroy the city and sanctuary. Is it a
coincidence when Jesus came claiming to
be the Messiah and he was cut off
that then troops came destroy Jerusalem
and the temple a second time? Its end
shall come with a flood and to the end
there shall be war. Desolations are
decreed. He shall make a strong
covenant. Now who is he? The prince. And
it's not make. He will confirm
a strong covenant with many for one
week. That's the last seven years.
Notice 483 years take place. But then
what about the last seven years? Because
the time here is 490 years. Well, here's
the last 70 years. He, the prince, will
confirm the covenant.
How how does he confirm? I'm going to
show you. and for half of the week in
the middle of the seven years he shall
make sacrifice and offering seas and in
their place shall be a desolate
desolating sacrilege. They will defile
the place. They will dishonor the place
until the decreed then is poured out
upon the desolator. Okay, now let me
show you how this is all fulfilled
in the destruction of Jerusalem. All
right, I'm going to show you that the
word make also means confirm.
And what it means confirm for seven
years. For seven years, he will confirm
what the covenant warned the Jews. If
you break covenant faithfulness,
your enemies will come slaughter you,
scatter you, right? Take you captive.
But it says in the middle of the week,
seven years, sacrifice will stop. Look
it up right now. Google this so you
don't think I'm lying. The Jewish war,
it began in 66 AD, lasted in 73 AD. Uh,
ended in 73 AD. How many years is that?
How many years is that? Count,
guys? Count. How many years?
66. Check it out if I'm lying. The
Jewish war 66 to 73 AD.
Now here it says in the middle of that
week 7 years he'll stop sacrifice.
Why? Because remember earlier it says
the sanctuary will be destroyed.
Is it a coincidence that the midpoint of
the seven years is 70 AD and the temple
was destroyed in 70 AD stopping the
sacrifice?
The middle,
the midpoint
would be 70 AD. Exactly.
The temple was destroyed, sacrifices
stopped.